This next story is one of those stories that
stretches the limits of the English language
to appropriately describe what has taken place.
Donald Trump wrote a letter to Turkish president
Erdogan about the entire fiasco going on in
Northern Syria with the Kurds.
And Trump pulling us troops there and the
letter was released.
But it is such a crazy letter that it seemed
like a fake letter because what Donald Trump
says in it, and we'll look at it in a second,
is a combination of childish and ludicrous
to a degree that makes it almost impossible
to believe.
And as a result, yesterday when the letter
was released, it took a while to catch on
on many news outlets and to be reported on
widely because it looks like it has to be
a fake letter.
We're going to look at it, but understand
that many media outlets hesitated to report
on this because it seems when you read it
almost impossible that this would really be
a letter from an American president to another
world, a world leader.
But it is, and it appears that the explanation
for it being so wacky is that Donald Trump
wrote it himself.
And that's of course the problem.
Let's take a look at it.
The letter is from October 9th it has now
been released and it says from Trump to Urdu
on, dear mr president, let's work out a good
deal.
You don't want to be responsible for slaughtering
thousands of people and I don't want to be
responsible for destroying the Turkish economy
and I will.
I've already given you a little sample with
respect to pastor Brunson.
I have worked hard to solve some of your problems.
Don't let the world down.
You can make a great deal.
General Muslim is willing to negotiate with
you and he is willing to make concessions
that they would never have made in the past.
I am confidentially enclosing a copy of his
letter to me.
Just received history will look upon you favorably.
If you get this done the right and humane
way, it will look upon you forever as the
devil.
If good things don't happen, don't be a tough
guy.
Don't be a fool.
I will call you later.
Sincerely, Donald Trump, it reads like what
the onion would publish or what Saturday night
live would have fake Trump played by Alec
Baldwin.
Read as a pretend letter from Trump to a world
leader.
But this is actually what Trump wrote.
It took multiple sources.
By the way, before I started, uh, considering
that it might be real after seeing friends
of mine posted on Facebook, I thought it was
a joke that was going around when we used
the term, the debasing and coarsening of the,
we're not just talking about Luna tick Trump,
is to don't understand how to talk about political
issues.
We're also talking about how Trump talks to
world leaders.
This letter now becoming exhibit a, the BBC
is now reporting that Erdogan quote, put the
letter in the bin.
When he received it translated from British
English, he threw it into the trash and ignored
it.
This is a letter that in total is, I mean,
what do we call it?
There are people calling it clinically insane,
but that doesn't seem to capture it and we
don't want to stigmatize mental illness.
Others are, once again talking about cognitive
decline, others are saying it's narcissism
personified.
The funniest or scariest thing about all of
this is that this actually seems like a letter
Trump wrote himself.
Rather than having someone else write it.
And this is what you end up with and even
more shocking, is that Trump released this.
Trump thinks this letter makes him look good.
He's proud of this letter.
This is like when he put out that bogus summary
of the Ukraine call thinking, this vindicates
me.
Everybody else looks at it and realizes, wait
a second, this is incriminating.
This is an incriminating document.
Uh, Trump's biggest claim to fame is that
he can negotiate that.
He can make deals.
And he writes a letter that looks like what
you would write in third grade if the teacher
says, okay, everybody, today we're going to
write a pretend letter to a president of the
a of another country.
This is what Republican voters, at least tens
of millions of them think is the art of the
deal and a big, tough negotiator.
But there's another thing out there, as I
told you earlier, one threw the letter out
and then bomb the hell out of the Kurds in
Northern Syria.
We knew it was a problem that Putin has Trump
by the balls, but Trump is so weak that the
Turkish president is simply ignoring Trump
and doing whatever he wants.
Remember when Trump ISTs told us under Trump,
the United States is going to be respected
again.
He threw the letter in the trash and did the
opposite of one of what Donald Trump seemed
to be telling him to do.
It's an embarrassing state of affairs for
the United States.
Let me know what you thought when you read
the letter a leave a reply.
If you're watching on YouTube, send me a tweet
at the Pacman.
If you are listening or watching elsewhere,
make sure to follow me on Twitter at D Pacman.
Follow the show while you're there as well.
At David Pakman show